Her low freak bitches.
There's that site,
that site that like I go to sometimes for that like,
can I handle this that he fucked.
You know,
you look at it and you're like,
yeah.
Sometimes
people send in their stuff all the time and sometimes it's like I can,
that's crazy.
And it sounds,
I was like,
Whoa,
whoa.
I can't handle that next.
My butthole pucker.
I do like the Fart stop.
Like some guys
I got,
yeah,
it was a guy and his nose was where in this girl's butt crack.
And then she saran wrapped his hair
and then she did parents and then she walked around the kitchen and she was
like,
turn the sink on and turned to just farting.
And he's like,
she's like,
yeah,
you're like those dirty Fars Huh?
Anything was Saran wrap,
like sack lunch,
sack lunch.
There's a sky that has Saran wrap diaper on and he just did the camera,
just pants to him and he spreads his cheeks and fills it with [inaudible].
But it's good.
Yeah,
that's good.
Just like
I just,
it's the sound,
it's the timing
pants and just the right.
And then it turns ever so slightly and the spread and the sound,
a woman's farts.
We talked about it for a while and then people wrote in,
people wrote in that were into it.
You know,
cause we were like,
they were telling us,
they were like,
yeah,
it goes back to like a pretty girl making something dirty.
I,
it's like,
oh my gosh,
so embarrassed.
So they,
this guy he wrote in that,
he was like my,
uh,
now he's grown,
his fiance knows and his colon,
like whenever she has to fight,
she calls him over and he gets so excited.
He loves it.
Come on.
How strange or people are so strange,
the variabilities of what people are attracted to.
It's just,
it's so bizarre.
Yeah.
Well you see like people that are into people that are so obese,
they can't get off the couch.
There's guys who turned on by that feeders,
feed them,
love their,
watch them.
And then there's girls who they have,
that's a whole business for them.
It's like they set up a camera and they're like,
oh,
eat cheese and cookies the day.
And then you just,
you get to watch them,
you know,
gaining weight should have done,
that's their whole thing.
New Shit.
Fucking comedy
jokes.
Just shit in bags.
Awesome.
I just,
the idea of Saran wrap and a guy's head.
You're so great areas.
So fun.
So this guy crawling around as she does her stuff in the kitchen or just
follows,
he needs those like slide or his need.
It's a really good idea.
We should suggest this board maybe and we've played a lot of uh,
I'm going to email this guy.
Why have these Omni Directional sliders that are work out with I do abs with
them.
You know this slide.
You can do it this way and do your mountain climbers with them.
I do all kinds of different shit.
Yeah,
you can put those on the guy's name.
Just fart or all around the house.
Hardwood floor.
Have you seen King Ash reppers work?
Um,
excuse me.
Pick him up.
What is that?
We've reached down a lot.
Offered him money.
Yes.
Just because he's such a creative guy.
When you're talking to me again and maybe
your powers.
King Ash ripper ass ripper.
Yeah,
Harry and grows
the Lord of all farts and gluttony.
He makes videos.
No himself.
Him King asked her about,
oh please give me some volume.
That's still
okay.
He is moving.
No real.
Oh go to ribbon.
Mattson farts.
Yeah,
go to ribbon.
Oh cause he has an opus.
This is just one of many.
But his pants.
Yeah,
he does.
It's getting brown.
There is 99,000 is how many fucking standup bits online of 199,009
does and eats to glutton.
So He's eating thing.
This is like,
Hey,
I
know about them.
We've studied his work forever.
Looking at Brown is getting back there.
I obviously isn't making money from this.
He should be making millions.
Does he have ads?
He's got to be making money.
If it's not,
it's got this.
Here's the thing,
what time does he have ads?
I liked that.
He's just checking everything else now.
The ads,
what's in the microwave?
She likes to stage the scene with
what we got
and
he's got marks in his underwear drawer.
Dude,
he's got some that are so brown.
Clearly.
Shit,
here's the car.
Here's a Christmas one too.
Hairy.
Gross Slob is his fucked him.
Yeah.
He,
oh my God.
Look at what he,
you fucking videos with hundreds of what he has to go to.
[inaudible] not much.
Sausage gravy.
Gluck has heel pizza watching you get to watch a meat.
Oh,
throw up.
This sounds hard to watch.
So I've as coming to the surface is Christmas one fucking Christmas special?
Yes.
Special.
We uh,
uh,
we found it on his,
because his live leak account,
he has a lot on live leak from youtube because youtube will take him down so
lively.
They,
it's just not apparently.
Maybe.
I think it gets flagged a lot on youtube and on lively.
It's lively.
It's like bring it on,
dude.
Someone's mom sees it.
What is my son being?
Boom,
those mothering mothering.
Well,
we're talking a lot about,
um,
crazy mother's lately.
Oh,
over-parenting yeah.
Well in this case he wasn't parents in this case,
this guy has got maybe was too much.
Maybe like rebellion,
right?
Yeah.
Hates Mommy magic.
His mom finds out about this.
I think he lives at homestyle because we've studied the videos and it seems as
though these are like prior to that location there was one that was up just a
bedroom in a basement and I think he actually did live with his folks and we've
deduced that this might be like a fetish thing because it's gluttony and then
farts and he won't answer any of my neighbors tweets or that people just bombard
him with him cause he put an email in one and we will on our show.
We're like everybody even unlike and no response know if you could get to the
bottom of this we'd really appreciate you.
I don't want to cause I'm terrified one day he'll be in here and the party in my
fucking Ergonomic chairs,
the family,
the family thing also is because on the Christmas one you can tell it's a family
home and then there's stockings up and he farts and every stocking
and then he goes,
that's what you get from King ass report for Merry Christmas.
Taking ass represents coast is probably going to die.
You probably have something wrong with his colon.
That's an interesting theory too.
And people have also
brought about the theory that he is uh,
doing that pushing air in there.
You know,
you think it's cheating,
he's cheating.
I believe that Tom like filling himself with air and then fighting it cause
there's know edits between each fart.
I don't know.
I would assume that he can't fart rapid fire that loud.
I mean you'd,
you'd have to be some sort of bag of wind,
like a bag genius,
right?
Cause sometimes mean regular,
fresh like oh little tell me your farts.
Smell like,
it sounded like last night I thought yesterday.
I,
you know,
when you stay away from seafood for awhile and then you reintroduce it,
there's bacteria in like,
you know,
it's different since shellfish and Sushi.
And I,
I thought when,
I guess the,
when I farted it sounded somebody was throwing up like the part sounded like a
guy going,
you know,
I,
I've only shaved my ass once in my life,
but once I did,
oh my God,
my fart sounded so different.
Really?
No,
they were all like wet and sloppy hair,
kind of different.
The hair on your ass literally changes the way your farts smell or sound rather.
Right?
Smell this smell the same,
but they sound different.
Plop,
plop,
plop.
Something tells me King Asher but doesn't shave.
That's a whole new area he get into.
That's a whole monster.
That guy,
she's dating that guy.
He doesn't have a girlfriend or girlfriend.
He scrapes up his youtube ad video money.
Then.
Then he gets a hooker farts on her
like,
no,
I hate it.
He said,
you fucking loser
my videos of jewelry.
Willows.
We went to the game,
right?
No you don't.
I don't have the Internet.
Shut up.
What?
The flood.
That's someone's babies from when I was a little baby.
Yeah,
they'd be your son.
It could be our son,
our son,
my favorite clothes.
Like take the throne,
the new king.
Hail to the new king.
I want him to go toe to toe.
I,
I hope he takes it from him one day.
Get to the next level.
What is it about Fart?
So there is so hilarious.
They're never not funny.
They're never not entertaining taboo.
You're supposed to do them in front of strangers.
The smell,
the sound,
everything's everything about it.
And the people,
the people that love them versus don't like it.
I think that's all rooted in.
If your household was okay with bars are not none growing up.
So that's why.
Oh,
trash.
So we loved farts.
Farts.
Okay.
Was it talked about in your house?
Was it no,
no,
no.
My house was lacking in any sense of humor.
Really?
Yeah.
No one was funny.
No one,
no one's funny.
No one had any ever.
Everyone was like,
don't be a loser.
Stop being a loser,
a loser,
dummy.
It was always,
you're going to be a loser.
You're grade soccer going to be skewed.
I'm still coughing from the fart sublime parts.
Um,
I literally almost threw up when he was eating the,
when he was hitting the hot dogs and sausage and the gravy saliva was coming to
the surface in my throat.
Now I'm dealing with right now.
He farts on what he's going,
he's
like
little Debbies 12 of them.
And then you're like,
all right.
And he turns around,
he's like more fart them any parts on him and then he eats them
guide to eating some of his own shit.
There's a video where he gets up bucket.
Okay.
IFC and dips,
every fried piece in Mayo and so horrible
Google search.
That guy
that's so crazy dies all wrong.
All wrong in every way.
I do kind of look there was a time where our listeners thought that I might get
him get this away him James,
we're literally almost threw up.
There is a,
there is one,
we won't describe anything.
There's nothing gross about this description but one time cause he's a eater.
He's like,
I got eight sausage egg mcmuffin and then he's,
he's,
he's tallying it and he's like D's a 250 calories and then I got egg and cheese,
300 calories.
Nine of those you do the math
because he wants you to know how many calories he's eating but he's not that
fat.
I just know God.
God on him.
Yeah.
He's not like he's,
he doesn't have some sort of Ralphie may thing going on.
It's like remarkably obese.
Sadly,
that guy lives his life like absolute shit every day and I'm fatter than him.
He definitely does not give a fuck ever.
And it was not that out of shape.
But you think that's an act?
I mean maybe he's like some customer service representative for like Toyo Tires
or someplace.
I might agree.
Have I not watched many of his films?
Are the data,
the footage for about
like a long time with king,
he claims to be in Michigan,
by the way.
He claimed to be a Michigan guy.
How long has he been doing this?
A few years.
So do you think he tentatively dipped him his toes into the pool of ass fart
videos or did he just fucking decide he's the king.
He calls himself.
He's the king from the jump though.
I mean,
did you go back to library does earlier videos where he's like,
I challenge anybody to Fart.
Like I can't.
Like he was really,
he owns it,
you know?
Yeah.
He's hard on all his haters.
He shows his face too.
Yeah,
he doesn't want gets recognized.
Do you think that he,
like one day he's at golden corral and then like gets you
getting shrimp nibblers I,
I think I'm going to go out on a limb here.
I'm going to go out on a limb and think and say that I don't know if he's all
mentally,
well,
I think
I've taken a big leap.
I think if you do a project like your king,
and he was like,
oh
my face foreign my face please sir,
your grace sat with site.
He'll be like,
dude,
I could park bigger than you any day like that.
And you know,
and having to be like,
Oh yeah,
I'm the king dude.
Name Ms. Dot.
Well what if you can only fight on his own?
What if like,
if you challenge him,
he just locks up.
It's interesting.
Yeah.
Maybe get stage fright.
Wow.
That's why he does it all alone.
And he's kitchen like a stage somewhere and he doesn't respond to the emails.
Let me ask you this.
If that guy put on a show somewhere,
like he had a small club in Chicago,
some hundred 50 seater.
Yeah.
Do you think he could fill a place?
You think you can get a hundred people in there?
I would endorse people go,
we would push harder.
I would buy a ticket.
I can make some money.
If he could fart like that all the time,
we can make some money and that's why I'd like him to contact us.
We can have him open for your mom's house.
Podcast live.
Yeah.
No,
you couldn't leave shit on your fucking microphone.
You want to hear anyway,
sorry.
No,
and you'd try to clean it up and do your show.
Oh,
I'm starting to throw.
Everybody would get so upset.
Oh,
we thought it was good to be cool.
It's got shit everywhere.
Okay.